bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 26 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour philippeco
votre rendez-vous d'information sur
l'actualité économique locale je vous
propose de découvrir les titres de cette
édition
la semaine dernière pierre Gattaz le
président du Medef est venu dans les
Yvelines pour mobiliser les patrons nous
étions sur place nous parlerons
également dans cette édition de tourisme
vert des points forts et nouveautés du
département présenté en exclusivité au
salon destination nature de Paris enfin
à l'occasion du salon de la franchise
2015 nous ferons un point sur le secteur
et sur le profil des franchisés enfin
dans notre entretien cette semaine il
sera question de la première édition des
Rencontres pour l'Emploi en
apprentissage et en alternance un
événement qui a lieu la semaine
prochaine à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour cela nous
sommes avec Pascal Cordet bonsoir Pascal
Corbel excusez-moi vous êtes le
vice-président chargé des relations
entre entreprises mais avant cela je
vous propose de passer en revue
l'actualité économique de la semaine
et pour commencer une information sur le
tourisme les Yvelines étaient à
l'honneur au salon destination nature de
Paris du 19 au 22 mars dernier
l'occasion pour Évelyne tourisme de
lancer la saison des randonnées dans le
département mais aussi de convier ses
partenaires comme France Miniature ou
encore l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines regardez ce
reportage de Sonia pro Aram et Williams
avec près d'un million et demi de
visiteurs en 2014 le département est
l'invité d'honneur du Salon destination
nature en partenariat avec le Mondial du
Tourisme l'occasion pour Évelyne
tourisme de présenter son nouveau site
internet dédié aux idées de randonnée
avec 70 000 hectares d'espaces boisés le
territoire détient la couverture
forestière la plus riche d’île-de-france
à pied à vélo ou encore à cheval toutes
les balades sont proposées sur un agenda
en ligne sur ce site internet vous avez
un agenda
trouver
toutes les randonnées possibles dans
tous les coins du département qu'on peut
faire en couple entre amis ou en famille
c'est à la fois une manière de découvrir
cette ville d'une autre façon de
randonner de découvrir les attraits du
département et faire venir de nouvelles
retombées économiques dans les villes et
sur le territoire
France Miniature a accueilli 160 000
personnes en 2014 au cœur du parc de
miniatures de monuments le plus grand
d'Europe le salon Destination Nature est
un salon qui est intéressant pour nous
puisque on rencontre beaucoup de
Parisiens de Franciliens et puis de
public qui est en cherchent de balades
en plein air donc c'est c'est idéal pour
nous anciennement connu sous le nom de
base de loisirs l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines change de nom
et en profite pour diversifier son offre
cette année donc on a mis cette
structure en place donc c'est du Home
Bowl on la met en place l'été dernier
c'est une nouveauté c'est la plus grande
structure de handball de France et ça
permet de jouer à trois contre trois
quatre contre quatre pour les jeunes les
enfants mais aussi les adultes entre
amis etc avec plus de 6 millions de
visiteurs par an le château de
Versailles demeure l'attraction
touristique phare des Yvelines mais avec
80% d'espaces verts 10 châteaux et une
quarantaine de musées le département
présente un atout économique complet
pour le tourisme francilien et je vous
le disais en titre la semaine dernière
pierre Gattaz le président du Medef
était dans les Yvelines il a donné une
conférence à La Celle-Saint-Cloud sur ce
thème compétitivité confiance et cap
avec serge Papin le PDG de systemu de
nombreux chefs d'entreprises yvelinois
étaient présents pour échanger avec les
deux hommes sur le futur de l'économie
dans le département et partager leurs
analyses et suggestions écoutez c'est
précisions recueillies au micro de
Michael à limiter au
il faut que le gouvernement et les élus
comprennent que ces dons étaient peu
dans ces PME que nous avons des
gisements d'emploi et de croissance
elles sont très nombreuses et il faut
vraiment travailler avec nos TPE avec
nos ppme et réduire la peur de
l'embauche dans ces TPE faire en sorte
que il y aime beaucoup moins de
contraintes qui posent sur elle et
d'améliorer la fiscalité je le vois dans
mon secteur pour ce qui concerne
l'agriculture les PME de
l'agroalimentaire il y a besoin d'un
accompagnement spécifique pour rentrer
de plain-pied dans la modernité et c'est
des choses que j'aimerais bien partager
avec Pierre Gattaz avec le Medef j'ai en
profiter ce soir et puis aussi un sujet
qui me tient à cœur c'est comment on
peut mieux intégrer les jeunes par
exemple dans l'entreprise voilà
et pour finir sur l'actualité les
chiffres du chômage qui ont été
communiqués hier dans les Yvelines le
chômage est en augmentation de 0,2% sur
la catégorie A par rapport au mois de
janvier sur un an on enregistre une
hausse de 4,6% sur les départements des
chiffres néanmoins en dessous de la
moyenne en Île de France les plus de 50
ans et les jeunes restent les catégories
les plus sensibles au chômage il est
maintenant temps de passer à notre
entretien de la semaine
je vous le disais nous recevons
aujourd'hui sur notre plateau Pascal
Corbel donc le vice-président à la
Direction des Relations Entreprises de
l'UVSQ donc vous avez participé à
l'organisation de cet événement en
partenariat avec la maison de l'emploi
qui s'appelle donc rencontre pour
l'emploi en alternance et en
apprentissage qui se déroule à
l'université de Versailles Versailles
Saint-Quentin le mercredi 1er avril de
9h à 17h si je me trompe pas et c'est
bien la première édition c'est ça c'est
tout à fait c'est la première édition de
ce forum alors est-ce que vous pouvez
m'en dire plus comment ça va se passer
comment va se dérouler ce forum alors
l'idée c'est de permettre la rencontre
entre ces jeunes vous avez dit juste
avant que le chômage touchait
particulièrement les jeunes et les
entreprises
parmi lesquelles parfois il y a une une
demande pour pour des apprentis qu'ils
ont du mal à pouvoir donc on va à la
fois rassembler les entreprises en
l'occurrence 33 entreprises
les jeunes des lycéens des demandeurs
d'emploi nos étudiants bien sûr autour
du thème de alternance et de
l'apprentissage avec des ateliers autour
leur permettant de mieux connaître cette
forme de formation
de d'apprendre comment mener un
entretien de recrutement également
donc voilà un ensemble complet pour
essayer de favoriser cette rencontre
entre les entreprises et les jeunes qui
cherchent des contrats en apprentissage
seront présentes c'est beaucoup ce sont
des entreprises locales qui sont
implantées justement à côté de
l'université ou alors sur le territoire
d'une manière générale oui et aussi bien
des grands groupes que des PME très bien
vous avez quelques exemples à me donner
par exemple la Sodexo
Air Liquide pour les grandes entreprises
et puis après des PME plus locales
pourquoi avoir choisi d'organiser cet
événement dans vos locaux à l'université
c'est un petit peu pour le prestige
c'est pour attirer plus d'universités
plus de jeunes alors il y a plusieurs
raisons d'abord nous avons des liens
très forts avec la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
donc c'est de ce type de coopération est
relativement courant il y avait déjà eu
des forums même si c'était pas sur
l'apprentissage organisé dans nos locaux
ensuite nous nous sommes très investis
dans l'apprentissage nous sommes la
troisième université en France en termes
de nombre d'apprentis avec à peu près
2400 apprentis chez nous donc nos
étudiants seront directement concernés
et puis je pense qu'il est important
aussi de changer un peu l'image de
l'apprentissage qui ne concerne pas
seulement même si ça les concerne aussi
les métiers manuels donc le fait de
l'organiser dans une dans une université
peut aussi contribuer à modifier cette
image même si il est important de le
dire ça n'est absolument pas réservé
pour autant aux étudiants c'est à dire
que là la liberté sera ouverte voilà
il me semble justement comment comment
va l'apprentissage à l'université c'est
vrai qu'on a pas tout à fait cette image
elles ont on se demande est-ce que c'est
difficile pour les jeunes les étudiants
qui sont avec plus de Bac +3 de trouver
des alternances dans les entreprises en
recherche beaucoup d'élèves c'est pas
vraiment un niveau où il est très
difficile en général de trouver un
contrat d'apprentissage après ça dépend
bien évidemment des thématiques des
formations en l'occurrence là nous
allons faciliter les choses pour nos
étudiants mais ce ne sont pas les plus
touchés par les problèmes pour trouver
des contrats d'apprentissage
effectivement les entreprises sont assez
friandes de futurs diplômés à bac + 3
bac + 5 en apprentissage donc même les
personnes qui sont avant même des
lycéens peuvent venir par exemple
un certain nombre de lycées qui ont
inscrit des classes entières le matin
donc nous allons accueillir plusieurs
centaines de lycéens quels conseils
donneriez-vous voilà des jeunes
étudiants peut-être des lycéens ou des
personnes plus âgées qui ont déjà
l'habitude voilà de pour venir à ces
rencontres qu'est-ce qu'il faut avoir à
mon CV une population à la fois faut-il
penser pour être efficace et voilà avoir
du succès dans ces entretiens alors
effectivement il faut venir avec son CV
puisque les entreprises sont là pour ça
pour les rencontrer
et vont repartir avec leur CV au niveau
des entretiens si on n'est pas encore à
l'aise si on ne sait pas trop comment
s'y prendre ne pas hésiter à passer par
l'atelier spécifique avant d'aller voir
les les entreprises et puis ensuite
quand on rencontre les entreprises
essayer d'être à l'écoute c'est à dire
de comprendre quels sont leurs besoins
pour voir si notre profil peut
intéresser ou pas c'est à dire ne pas se
mettre dans une position de voilà je
cherche un contrat mais plutôt j'offre
mes services très bien et bien merci
beaucoup parce qu'il y a Corbel d'être
venu sur notre plateau je le rappelle
donc la cette rencontre le pour l'emploi
en alternance et en apprentissage a lieu
mercredi 1er avril de 9h à 17h dans le
hall de l'Université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parce que
maintenant à l'entreprise de la semaine
dans un contexte économique plutôt morne
le secteur de la franchise tient bon
face à la crise il pèse aujourd'hui près
de 51,4 milliards d'euros de plus en
plus de personnes se tournent vers cette
solution à l'occasion du salon de la
franchise nous avons rencontré un
yvinois qui s'est lancé dans l'aventure
un reportage réalisé avec William elle
Sonia proaram et Mathilde cap Berne
fait partie des 68171 entrepreneurs
français à avoir choisi la franchise
entrée comme manager dans cette pizzeria
des clés sous bois en 1989 il est devenu
gérant puis a choisi de le Salier avec
la maison mère en 2002 une décision qui
est selon lui présente beaucoup
d'avantages
sur notre métier notre vrai métier qui
est la fabrication de pizza livrée à
domicile plutôt que rechercher des
partenaires on a un soutien de la part
du franchiseur qui nous aide dans la
recherche de locaux qui nous aide
également dans la recherche et
l'implantation du local dans les travaux
et dans le recrutement du personnel dans
la formation une enseigne comme celle-ci
nécessite un investissement de près de
260000 euros dont 80000 euros d'apport
pour le franchisé il reverse ensuite un
pourcentage de son chiffre d'affaires à
la maison mère il est d'environ 15% mais
ce chiffre peut varier selon les
enseignes le franchiseur est indépendant
jusque dans une certaine mesure
du moment où on exploite une enseigne on
se doit de respecter les normes les
chartes et les engagements
pour la renommée pour garder une bonne
image ancienne employée salarié en
reconversion ou entrepreneurs ils sont
nombreux à se tourner vers la franchise
en 2014 le nombre de points de vente
franchiser étant hausse avec 3000 38
unités supplémentaires cela représente
une croissance de 4,7% par rapport à
2013 l'aventure est attractive mais ne
s'adresse pas à tout le monde il faut
intégrer certaines contraintes le
franchise c'est l'ambassadeur de
l'enseigne c'est lui qui a le
l'obligation de rendre la promesse faite
par l'enseigne aux clients donc il a le
contact client il est terrain et il est
sur le court terme c'est à dire que si
la boutique doit être peinte en verte
parce que c'est le concept qui veut que
ce soit vert il l'a peindra pas en rouge
donc s'il est pas prêt à jouer ce rôle
d'ambassadeur et d'être proche de la
clientèle et de reproduire fidèlement le
concept auprès de la clientèle il vaut
mieux qu'il reste commerçant indépendant
isolés en 2014 on compte 77 enseignes de
franchiseur de plus en 2013 cette hausse
de 4,5% en un an fait figure de
performance au vu de la quasi stagnation
de l'économie française en 2014
et c'est la fin de notre émission merci
de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez-vous jeudi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de Philippo où il sera
notamment question de la Semaine de
l'Industrie je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée